[Music]  people are looking for money-saving ways  to buy gifts and decorations for the  holidays that's where we come in once  again here with some money saving  holiday tips is our prop master bill  tall bill unwrapped the ticket poem take  the foil put it in the shredder  boom tinsel  [Music]  here's bill with another tip take a  bottle of tide stick some antlers on it  boom Yuletide  here's another one take a bag of cocaine  stick a carrot in it  boom snowman  [Music]  how's that money safety I've got all  this cocaine laying around here's  another one steal someone's credit card  write iTunes on it  boom gift card and here's wine more take  some duct tape stick it on your  mother-in-law's mouth  boom silent night  [Applause]